ALEX DANILO: They didn't
know what to expect.
And I kind of thought
when we went there,
they might find
this really boring.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So you know where
we are, people?
This in Sydney Olympic
Stadium, and this
is like the future of Olympics.
Never mind human competition,
this is robot against robot.
This is like machines.
When I was a kid, I
think like any kid
you don't really know what you
want to do when you grow up.
I don't think I ever
planned to be an engineer.
I think just going
into engineering
was just a side effect of
enjoying building things.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So these teams are putting
their robots together.
This is like a real
robot right here.
Check this out.
Let's have a look.
Mainly it's like actuators.
There's motors here.
There's stressed out cables.
There's chains.
There's all these control wires.
Servers are probably
in there somewhere.
Wow.
Would you like to build a robot?
BOY: I don't think so.
ALEX DANILO: Why not?
BOY: Because they could
electrocute people.
ALEX DANILO: When kids see
robots or think of robots,
they probably think of
movies and cartoons,
and that's just not reality.
Today cars are
built with robots.
A lot of the consumer
electronics you buy
is built with robots.
Tons of things are
built with robots,
and they are not only
changing the world,
they'll continue to
change the world.
And if you take the kids
to actually show them
what they do, they
might get interested,
and they might want to
actually do stuff themselves.
So this is a LEGO brick
which controls everything.
And there's cables connecting
to all the motors and stuff,
and they're letting
all sorts of stuff.
Is it fun?
GIRL: Yes.
ALEX DANILO: What do you think?
BOY: I think so.
ALEX DANILO: I think
they're having fun.
BOY: How do you program these
robots to be so efficient?
WOMAN: The team
spent a lot of time
ensuring that they keep their
robots as simple as possible
because simple is a very
good engineering practice.
BOY: OK.
ALEX DANILO: What
did you like most
about the robotics competition?
BOY: I liked everything.
Nothing was my favorite.
GIRL: I liked making
the LEGO Rover.
It was really fun.
ALEX DANILO: Right.
So did your LEGO
robot go really well?
GIRL: Yes.
ALEX DANILO: Do you think
you'll build bigger robots when
you're a bit older?
GIRL: Yes.
ALEX DANILO: There were
just smiles on their faces--
excited.
It just opened their
eyes to a new world,
and that world is the world of
technology, and it can be fun.
And unless you see it for
yourself, you can never know.
OK, so there you have it, kids.
The First Robotics
Competition is a great way
to get into robotics.
These little ones, they
can make LEGO robots.
The big kids can
make bigger robots.
So what do you guys think?
Shall we go build a robot?
BOY AND GIRL: Yeah!
ALEX DANILO: Come on.
[MUSIC PLAYING]